in cities across the country young and
mostly unemployed Iraqis are directing
their anger at officialdom they blame
the government for failing to create
jobs the authorities heavy-handed
response to the protests only increases
their resentment we are peaceful but
they meet us with bullets and tear gas
the government is fighting us but we
will carry on we will not retreat
University graduate Mustapha Hill is
working as a shopkeeper to make ends
meet corruption everywhere graduated
from the same College as me she was
unemployed there is no work and that's
because of corruption in the government
they promised but they never deliver two
years after the end of the war against
the so-called Islamic state terror group
there's little sign of any peace
dividend one in four young Iraqis are
out of work basic services like water
and electricity are unreliable hospitals
roads and schools all lack funding young
people have no jobs and no money the
country is taking money from abroad but
it doesn't benefit our own people we are
very tired we say those who are corrupt
should go we are protesting for our
rights
even the government admits the
protesters are right to demand an end to
corruption
the Prime Minister is proposing a new
law granting families a basic income
that may not be enough to end the unrest
in the short term
Iraqi journalist Semiramis Aoi is now in
the studio to talk about the situation
in the country good morning to you Amir
nice to see you again you you're back
about a week now from Iraq what what
triggered these protests did did you
have a sense they were coming when you
were over there you you know they have
as clear demands they just want to
reducing the unemployment especially
with that people has been graduated from
the college from the universities and
also fighting or ending the corruption
which is flat over Iraqi institution in
the government and beside of that the
public service like simple things
hospitals a garbage electricity water
and so on we should not forget that Iraq
spent food from 2005 to now about 450
billion dollars for that sector and
nothing happened really those are some
incredible numbers 450 billion you know
when you look at these protests and how
quickly they've spread across the
country you know there's a big question
can the Iraqi government survive this
this level of protest I think it depends
on what's going to happen today and
tomorrow and in the next 24 hours I
think the most important thing what is
going to happen today in the Friday with
the speech of mirja the religious leader
in Najaf whether they are going to give
him a last chance to survive for mr.
prime minister abdul mattie and the
second things is also the protesters
coming from the political part of
moqtada al-sadr also a religious leader
which also part of participating in the
government what are going they they're
going to do I think the next two 40 40
48 hours it's really very important
whether the government is going to
respond or or nuts
we should wait okay now when we say
these protesters spread across the
country
they spread across the mainly Shia areas
so far the Sunni and the Kurds have not
been joining in these protests why is
that for the Sunni cities they are
really tired from the fighting against
lemak so called Islamic state and the
second also there the allegation if they
went to the go to the streets there is
allegation that they could support the
Islamic state and they want to come back
that's why there is calm at that cities
the second and also Kurds they have
almost public services in the end of the
day the Shia in the south cities they
were the main player in the war against
Islamic state and they wait two years
after that battle and Mosul and so on
just to enhancing that situation nothing
happens okay Amir I'm sorry great to see
you again thanks so much for coming in -
thank you very much